[Music]
the woman caught on camera physically
attacking a black teenager and falsely
accusing him of stealing her cell phone
has been arrested in california it
happened last night
you might remember this video mia
poncetto approached fourteen-year-old
keon harold jr at a new york city hotel
last month accusing him
of stealing her phone his father jazz
musician
keon harrell recorded the encounter and
accused poncetto
of racial profiling
now the video shows poncetto trying to
stop the teenager from leaving the hotel
lobby and then rushing toward them
hotel surveillance video shows the 22
year old woman
tackling keon junior now he never had
the phone it turned up several minutes
later at the hotel
new york city detectives went to
california yesterday to coordinate
poncetto's arrest in connection with the
confrontation
she was contacted at a traffic stop in
ventura county near los angeles
officials say that police had to pull
her out of the car when she refused to
get out
now in an exclusive interview we had
just done that interview yesterday
afternoon her lawyer spoke with us
before she was arrested they told us
that nypd had not yet contacted them
mia help me understand what made you
think that keon had your phone
that's why i'm confused why did you
think he had it i was approaching
the the people that had been exiting the
hotel because in my mind
anybody exiting is probably the one that
might be the one that is
trying to steal my phone i admit yes i
could have approached the situation
differently or maybe not yelled at him
like that and made him feel
you know maybe some sort of uh inferior
way making him feel as if i was like
hurting his feelings because that's not
my intention i
i consider myself to be super sweet i
really never ever meant
for it to like hurt him or his father
either are you saying that you were
stopping everybody in the lobby
asking them about your phone is that
what you're saying um not everyone just
the
just the people that in the meantime
while the hotel manager was
checking the k the footage i just wanted
to do my part as best as i could
you just described yourself as super
sweet i know you've seen the video when
you look at the video
the reaction seems very extreme it
doesn't seem like
it's someone who's super sweet how would
you feel if you were alone in new york
and you know you're going to spend time
with your family during the holidays
and you lose the one thing that gets
stolen from you that has all the access
to the only way that you're able to get
back home
i just don't think i would randomly
attack people is what i'm saying to you
i know you said you could have handled
it better but i just don't think i would
randomly attack people in the manner in
which you did what do you think when you
look at that video
you're standing there in your leggings
and your flip-flops and it looks like
you're just going
nuts for lack of a better word no i'm
not letting him walk away with my phone
i don't feel that that is who i am as a
person i don't feel like this one
mistake does define me but
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the sun feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings or
the father's feelings i don't believe
one mistake defines anybody
but i i think when i look at that
particular video
you're you did more than just accuse him
the video seems to show that you
physically
attacked this young boy you do see that
too
right by the end of the day the dad did
end up like
slamming me to the ground and uh pulling
my hair and
throwing me and dragging me across the
ground so
i i will say that yeah but but i think
you know the video we saw it looked like
you had just attacked his son
yeah the footage shows me attacking his
son
of attacking him how yelling at him yes
okay i apologize can we move on
i know you're saying i don't need to i'm
just want to apologize but i do think
that
there should be some context to your
actions that day
okay so basically i'm i'm
a 22 year old girl i am i i don't
i racism uh is
i said i how is one girl accusing
a guy about a phone
a crime where is the context in that
is the deeper what is the deeper what is
the deeper yeah it's not it's
that's not the problem you have to at
least understand your actions that day
you seem to have attacked this little
boy this young boy this
yes teenager you seem to have attacked
this teenager about the phone
and then it turned out he didn't even
have your phone
that's the thing i mean you're you're
saying look i'm 22 years old you're 22
years old but you are old enough to know
better
so i will say you're 22. i killed it
enough
the hotel did have my phone the hotel
did i end up having my phone
i did get my belongings returned to me
that was my favorite part enough now the
herald family's lawyer released a
statement last night they said this is
not about an apology from someone who
until a few days ago was claiming she
did nothing wrong and in fact
allege that keon harold senior had
assaulted her someone who targeted a 14
year old black teenager
because of the color of his skin we'll
have more of our interview with
miss with with miss mia onset
on monday you know i actually felt for
the attorney there who was really trying
to help her and then
you know when she interjected uh mia
would get upset about that
she insisted that she's not racial
profiling she has an explanation about
that
and you know it was reported that an
uber driver returned the phone she says
that's not true so she's
she wanted to make an apology but as i
said to her in the interview i'm not
sure you're helping yourself here
well the point is he didn't have her
phone no he did not and
did not interesting choice of hat but
yeah
also the point is the video footage is
pretty clear and she doesn't seem
quite ready to acknowledge what it shows
her lawyer sharon sitting by her
her side tried to help her it's
interesting you would point out the hat
because
sharon said you know you might want to
remove that hat and she refused to do
that too it was an interesting
afternoon and at the time you know i
said have nypd been in touch with you
they had not so it was
interesting that right after that after
that interview that she was stopped and
then
arrested well she said she'd understand
why it's a crime well she might she
might learn now
yeah yeah it's a very sad story though
really is a very sad story
something sad about her and the fact
that the trauma that she put